personal thank you for me to you guys
for enjoying my little cartoon demons
from my Annabelle review not gonna lie
that took forever to make so thank
you for liking it you're awesome gone
girl so gone girls directed by David
Fincher's based off of a novel
ultimately you have Ben Affleck and
Rosamund Pike they're a married couple
everything seems happy and then one day
Ben Affleck comes home and his wife's
missing it looks like there are signs of
a struggle this is a little media thing
going on my wife's missing you're like
oh that sucks for Affleck but
immediately you're like did he do it cuz
you know you suspect cuz you're normal
he starts revealing her diary and you're
like maybe the husband did do it so now
we have a missing person movie that's
ultimately you feel like it's a murder
mystery from the get-go that's what I
loved about this movie you feel like an
onlooker you feel like you have felt a
million times before when you see a
story like this on the news you're like
I don't know all the facts I just see
what the media is showing me so the
whole time you're like is he just an
awkward guy or is he a sociopath he
killed his wife that's really intriguing
I like that you don't know who to root
for this movie starts taking twists and
turns none of which bored me I like that
movie like this I don't want to see it
go from A to Z alright nice little bow
done I want twists and turns in there
keep me interested this movie certainly
keeps you interested important because
this movie's long holy I'll get
into that later of it yeah
first of all everyone did a great job in
this movie Ben Affleck did a good job
rosemon Pike that's the one right there
that's the ticket this lady steals the
show
I didn't think that was possible the
only thing that she's done that stands
out in my mind is she was a Bond girl at
one point other than that I can't name a
thing that she's done that I remember
until this movie this is the Rosamund
Pike movie yeah she's good another
really impressive performance in this
movie from someone who has never
impressed me in the entirety of his
career Tyler Perry Tyler Perry was
awesome he is the lawyer that Ben
Affleck's character gets because he's
ultimately the Johnnie Cochran he does
this and he was awesome in this
role so all those people I'm like I
don't know who else I would have cast in
that role I'm glad they got Tyler Perry
I said that I'm glad they got Tyler
Perry for this role look I don't dislike
Tyler Perry he's just never impressed me
with anything until now I like the mix
of really serious tone to humor that
this movie has at first I was like it's
that conflicting and then I quickly
shove that on my head of like no it's
not what it is is it's real it's really
realistic in any situation especially a
heavy situation like this in real life
there are going to be people that
lighten the mood
step into the room and they'll say
something and there will be those people
that just they make a joke or they
lighten the minoan is serious a hundred
percent of the time if they are those
are called boring people and don't come
to my party ever getting to this movies
length this movie is a long movie when
the end credits hit everyone got out of
their seats and start funneling out of
the movie theater everyone in that
theater has seen marvel movies no one
gave a if there's a post-credits
scene I noticed on a Marvel movie
I'm just saying they've conditioned us
at this point say that everyone held
their pain no one no one wanted to take
a break I had a soda in the movie I was
like man I gotta go I've had to go for
an hour I want to miss a bigger part
this one you know what movies good is
when you will not take that piss break I
just feel like the last part of this
movie you could have just cut out just
Rock the movie out I don't say that
lightly because there's still relevant
content in there I'm just saying the
movie ends up cutting off anyways like
and and so you could've just done that
like 15 minutes prior and be like and
that being said though this movie is
really well acted for being as long as
it is it keeps you interested it's heavy
content you're engrossed you want to get
to the answers you want to find out the
answers before the cop finds out the
answers you feel like you're the
detective you're watching everything
Affleck does you're sizing it up you're
like all right what doesn't add up here
everyone killed it in this movie I
really enjoyed the movie a lot it's not
a movie I'm gonna go out there and see a
lot but I did enjoy it a lot I'm gonna
say gone girl is definitely worth buying
on blu-ray
it's your favorite David Fincher movie
out there that's a good question what is
your favorite whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more